temperaturas extremas alrededor del
globo una ola de calor histórica azota
países como México India y Estados
Unidos en Texas los termómetros han
alcanzado más de 38 grados en las
últimas semanas lo que ha provocado la
muerte de 13 personas en el Estado
Sureño en vísperas de las celebraciones
por el día de la independencia las
autoridades llaman a tomar precauciones
en los festejos al aire libre
tengan cuidado de no dejar a nadie en el
coche incluidas las mascotas y cuando
salgamos a celebrar el 4 de julio vengan
preparados
al norte de México las temperaturas
llegan a más de 40 grados autoridades
federales han reportado el fallecimiento
de 112 mexicanos en las últimas semanas
por golpes de calor científicos
advierten que de no acelerar las labores
contra el cambio climático estas
temperaturas récord podrían estar por
debajo de la media de años venideros
Porque estos acontecimientos no entran
en juego con negociaciones y pruebas
vivas de que el cambio climático está
ocurriendo ahora y solo van a empeorar
ni siquiera van a convertirse en la
nueva normalidad en el futuro este tipo
de fenómenos estarán por debajo de la
media en la India algunas localidades al
sur del territorio enfrentan hasta 45
grados Un calor extremo que se ha
cobrado la vida de más de 100 personas
desde el 15 de junio y que pone a prueba
la capacidad hospitalaria del país